[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 6 novembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv
60,18 l'actualité locale en 26 minutes
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition elle a pris tout récemment ses
fonctions de rectrice de l'académie de
versailles charline avenel était en
visite ce matin dans les yvelines au
collège des essarts le roi un
déplacement sur le thème de la sécurité
dans les écoles quelques jours après les
annonces du ministre de l'éducation
nationale sur le sujet les gilet jaune
donne rendez vous le samedi 17 novembre
une grande journée de blocage sur les
routes de france contre la hausse des
prix du carburant le gouvernement
n'entend pas reculer mais souhaite
mettre en place des mesures de
compensation nous en parlons avec et
daniel quéro président de 40 millions
d'automobilistes
et ce nouveau mot fait également notre
invité jean christophe jenson est l'un
des lauréats du concours un des
meilleurs ouvriers de france
l épreuve finale se dérouler jusqu'au 24
octobre
l'illinois et le chef pâtissier de la
maison lenôtre depuis 2006 mais avant de
développer ces titres un homme de 35 ans
en état de mort cérébrale
hier après midi il a été roué de coups
par six hommes près du lycée 17 mar à
maurepas et les agresseurs ont pris la
fuite une enquête a été ouverte et
confiée à la police judiciaire de
versailles
c'est un premier déplacement pour la
nouvelle rectrice de l'académie de
versailles et charline avenel était au
collège des molières aux essarts-le-roi
ce matin et visite forcément teinté par
le contexte national
quelques semaines seulement après qu'une
professeur était braquée par son élève à
créteil les précisions de manon varaldo
échanger sur les actions mises en place
pour préserver un climat scolaire serein
lors de sa venue au collège les molières
des essarts le roi charline avenel a pu
rencontrer l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative professeurs membres du
rectorat parents d'élèves
c'est un collège qui
a su mettre en place les conditions d'un
climat apaisé
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
a également présenté les mesures
annoncées par le ministre de l'éducation
sur la protection des écoles
parmi elles une organisation des
conseils de discipline simplifier la
présence d'un policier ou d'un gendarme
lorsque le contexte le nécessitent une
mesure effective dans le collège les
molières qui a déjà fait appel à une
policière
autre mesure annoncée une période
probatoire sera instaurée après une
exclusion
chaque jour l'élève fera le point sur sa
journée avec le cpe où le chef
d'établissement venir voir un adulte
pour que on crée une situation de retour
à l'école me semble important le mot
quotidien et les plus gênants cette
mesure parce que c'est difficile pour
nous d'être au quotidien avec un et la
compliquer soigner le retour d'un élève
en difficulté ça me semble très
important
le mot quotidiennement et peut-être un
peu compliqué être confrontés au manque
de respect d'un élève ou comment gérer
le retour d'un exclut les enseignants
ont interpellé la rectrice sur leur
besoin d'être accompagnés dans
l'exercice de l'autorité envers leurs
élèves ce qui ressort des échanges que
nous avons eus ce matin c'est le besoin
des enseignants d'être accompagné dans
l'exercice de leur autorité et en cas de
difficulté par l'ensemble de la chaîne
pédagogique et aussi en matière de
formation prochainement l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative souhaite appliquer
des sanctions dites de
responsabilisation travaux d'intérêt
général devoirs supplémentaires
des mesures auxquelles les
établissements font appel dans seulement
1% des cas dans l'actualité du jour en
forum emploi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il se tient
jusqu'à 22 heures organisée par le
groupe aura nos le groupe spécialisé
dans l'énergie recrues de cette année
1500 postes d'ingénierie de projet
d'assainissement ou encore de
radioprotection au vélodrome aujourd'hui
250 métiers représentés des entretiens
d'embauché en direct écouter ses propos
au micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
le groupe aura nos est implanté en île
de france il y à son siège
à la défense mais les la plupart de ses
collaborateurs travaillent dans le
domaine de l'ingénierie des projets et
de la logistique nucléaire à saint
quentin en yvelines et donc il nous a
semblé logique comme ce sont des
activités qui recrutent beaucoup dit
tenir notre forum de l'emploi à saint
quentin en yvelines au plus près de nos
activités opérationnelles de projets
d'ingénierie et de logistique nucléaire
et ce forum se tient jusqu'à ce soir
mardi à 22h jusqu'à ce soir mardi 22
heures au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines est le rendez vous
est fixé ce samedi 17 novembre et gilet
jaune mouvement un citoyen appelle à une
grande journée de blocage en france pour
protester contre la hausse des prix du
carburant dans les yvelines plusieurs
blocages à prévoir notamment sur les
autoroutes a10 a12 et a13 également les
nationales es10 es12 bonsoir daniel
tireau oui bonsoir vous êtes le vous
êtes yvelinois et vous êtes le président
de l'association de défense des usagers
de la route 40 millions d'automobilistes
est-ce que déjà vous serez dans la
mobilisation le 17e rang tant que
citoyen certainement nous sommes pas
organisateur de manifestation mais nous
nous avons déjà alerté le président de
la république dès le mois de septembre
delà du mécontentement qui monte qui
monte dans le pays et nous en voulons
ces coups de pompe c'est aux ut
pontpoint comme en demandant à chaque
citoyen concerné de de cliquer sur le
lien et vous aviez une belle que vous
pouvez envoyer au président république
avec le ticket de caisse de la
station-service
voilà donc on a senti ce mouvement monte
pas ce qu'on comprend pas bien c'est on
nous a mis 7 centimes d'augmentation sur
le diesel mais aussi 4 centimes sur
l'essence et le sud du désert qui
aujourd'hui au dessus du prix de
l'essence
oui pratiquement et les gens ne
comprennent pas puisque jusqu'à il ya
quelques années on encourager les gens à
acheter des moteurs diesel et maintenant
via les taxes et on comprend pas bien
pourquoi et on voudrait nous faire
croire qu'il suffirait de taxer les
carburants en france pour réduire la
température de la planète
le vrai que c'est quand même un peu gros
alors c'est vrai qu'il est les raisons
avancées par le gouvernement sont
notamment écologique il faut se passer
du tout pétrole ça c'est edouard
philippe qui le dit pour commencer à
organiser la transition
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire ça c'est
la justification je regardais justement
les prix des carburants en europe pour
ce qui concerne le gazole qui est le
premier concerné vous avez capecchi sont
légèrement au-dessus 1 la belgique le
royaume-uni l'italie et la norvège et
tous les autres sont largement en
dessous ce qui veut dire que nous avec
un pour cent de la population mondiale
en france on serait capable à nous seuls
veut faire baisser la température de la
terre ça ne marche pas on voit bien
qu'on a été supprimé la taxe
d'habitation n'a il ya un problème pour
boucler le budget de l'état et les taxes
viennent aider à boucler le budget de
l'état pas d'accord sur le fait qu'il
faille changer les comportements
aujourd'hui se tait ça que ça se passe
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut faire
confiance à la science à la technique le
débat sur le diesel
il est devenu idéologique et et comme en
politique alors qu'il faudrait sur s'en
tenir je dirais à tout ce qui est
scientifique et on trouve des solutions
aux scientifiques et techniques les
allemands par exemple qui sont
confrontés au même problème
aujourd'hui il ya à travailler ensemble
entre le gouvernement allemand et les
constructeurs pour faire en sorte que
les vieux diesels ya les vieux diesels
effectivement qu'il peut lui faut les
sortir
et puis il est uni mais la conversion à
la mis en place de 1000 euros en place
deux mille euros pour les personnes vrai
opposable essayé d'expliquer à quelqu un
qu avec 2000 euros et pour acheter un
véhicule moins polluant avec une hybride
ou un véhicule électrique
c'est vraiment de la communication 5-0
alors j'en ai le président qu'il est ce
matin ya là deux cent mille quand même
qu'ils ont demandée avant la prime
200000 il ya 5 millions de voitures qui
se vendent chaque année d'occasion et 2
millions de neuf donc sur 7 millions de
voitures achetées il ya deux cent mille
qui sont concernés ces 2 8%
on voit bien que c'est de la
communication mais par rapport à tout ce
qu'on a ponctionné sur le dos de
l'automobiliste et sais rien parce que
si emmanuel macron par noah a justement
annoncé ce matin qu'il allait mettre en
place le gouvernement et mettre en place
une aide pour les automobilistes qui
font plus de 30 kilomètres par jour pour
se rendre sur leur lieu de travail je
vous propose de l'écouter il était
l'invité d'europe 1 tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui doivent se déplacer faire en
effet plus de 30 ou 40 kilomètres chaque
jour pour aller travailler qui en plus
de sa doivent aller rechercher des
enfants il faut que là on est sur le
mode un peu la philosophie c'est un peu
l'indemnité kilométrique il
travailler avec les collectivités
locales les employeurs intelligemment
pour aider ces gens là parce que nos
concitoyens qui sont dans cette
situation je comprends leur colère ils
se sentent pris au piège vous l'avez
entendu c'est une et ils me disent à
juste titre ceux qui restent à la maison
ceux qui ont la chance de pouvoir
habiter à côté de leur travail
eux sont pas pénalisés moi c'est un peu
la double peine j'ai pas les moyens
d'habiter à côté de l'endroit où je
travaille je suis un courage ou une
courageuse je me lève tous les matins
pour aller travailler et moi on pénalise
donc il faut pouvoir les étés le
président de la république a dit
également qu'il fallait travailler avec
les collectivités pour mettre en place
cette mesure qui d'ailleurs déjà mises
en place dans les hauts de france c'est
quand même assez extraordinaire parce
que là on met une taxe et après on va
faire un chèque pour venir déduire pour
aider ceux qui sont victimes de
l'attaqué
il aurait été quand même beaucoup plus 5
de pompe augmenter la taxe on est en
train de monter encore nouvelle usine à
gaz comme on sait bien le faire ici le
prime a pris une traction et en plus on
dit mais c'est pas nous qui allons faire
le chèque ça va de les collectivités
locales ça va peut-être les entreprises
on sait pas bien qui mais j'entendais
tout à l'heure
certains présidents de région qui
commencent à rouspéter certains chefs
d'entreprise commerciale paie des taxes
et après c'est à nous de payer les flux
devraient comprends pas c'est la région
qui a mis en place entre cassette est
dans les automatismes et irait payer on
a déjà diminué des allocations aux
régions et maintenant on voudrait encore
leur faire payer une taxe qui a été mise
là pour boucler un budget on le voit
très bien et et qui finalement pourquoi
on monte pour distribuer après un check
j'assemble a probablement et cohérent
qu'est ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement recule vous le dites 40
millions d'automobilistes interpelle le
gouvernement depuis depuis septembre
parce que finalement si on veut s'y joue
vraiment c'est le motif écologique faut
travailler avec les constructeurs faut
travailler avec la science et à la
technologie
on voit bien d'ailleurs que tout s'est
amélioré puisque vous regardez les on
parle beaucoup du diesel les émissions
de particules fines ont été divisées par
deux en vingt ans ce qui veut dire que
la technologie permet de rendre de plus
en plus propres les véhicules donc tout
ça on le fait en concertation autour des
solutions en allemagne en allemagne ils
ont décidé de sortir les vieux véhicules
diesel et pour tous ceux qui peuvent
être rénové régler ajouter des filtres à
particules et bien il y aura un effort
conjoint entre les constructeurs et
loueurs nouveau là bas on cherche des
solutions ici on punit et
et on taxe vous pensez que le
gouvernement peut reculer en cas de
grosse mobilisation a dit cette norme
sur un autre sujet dans les années 2000
gouvernement avait reculé par exemple la
société aes que la sueur sûr on en
entend parler partout où j'ai été
pendant quelques jours en province
j'entendais provinciaux quand vous allez
faire votre main vous entendez parler
j'étais dans un lieu où il y avait des
personnes âgées en train de se distraire
et en parlait en disant mais on y arrive
plus j'étais obligé de couper mon
chauffage voyez donc c'est un mouvement
de fond
les gens sont mécontents ils ne
comprennent pas donc à un moment ou un
autre faudra peut-être reculer merci
daniel tireau d'avoir été avec nous et
et président de l'association 40
millions d'automobilistes et vous pouvez
d'ailleurs retrouver toute l'actualité
de cette association sur son site
internet la suite à présent de notre
dossier sur les déserts médicaux nous
nous intéressons ce soir aux permanences
d'installation des médecins elles sont
organisées une fois par mois la ceppm de
versailles ou au conseil de l'ordre des
médecins des yvelines les praticiens
participent à des entretiens individuels
pour accompagner leur projet
d'installation en pratique libérale un
reportage de nicolas d'andré de manon
varaldo des permanences d'installation
mensuel pour préparer les médecins à la
pratique libérale un moyen de remédier
au problème des zones sous denses
cette praticienne en remplace
actuellement deux médecins sur
versailles et le ch est née elle a
décidé de s'installer avec une consoeur
cette réunion nous aident à
à savoir quelles procédures engagées
dans quel ordre surtout parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'intervenants a rencontré
avant l'installation définitive et c'est
parfois un peu flou il faut
effectivement aider à l'installation il
faut donner envie aux internes en
médecine de faire de la médecine de
ville qui n'a rien à voir avec la
médecine hospitalière alors il ya
maintenant beaucoup plus de stages en
cabinet libéral qu'auparavant mais moi
c'est vraiment mon stage de médecine
libérale qui m'a donné envie à près de
m'installer promouvoir l'activité
libérale en accompagnant les médecins
dans leur projet l'objectif de ces
réunions individuelles des conseils de
l' agence régionale de santé de l'union
régionale des professionnels de santé de
l'ordre des médecins et de l'assurance
maladie
il ya quand même des projets assez
émouvant qui sont pas très loin de votre
notre lieu d'installation prévu je vous
dis juste si jamais cela que vous
correspondre il ya des aides qui peut
vous permettre de démarrer si nous avons
un médecin qui a vraiment un projet très
stabiliser les conseils vont pas être
les mêmes car médecin qui va nous parler
d'une commune effectivement le rôle de
la herray cela va être de mettre de
faire le lien avec les communes qui sont
en demande de médecins donc il me
contacter par téléphone portable par
mail et on les accompagne jusqu'au
moment de leur installation voir un
petit peu après quand ils ont des
questions très concrètes ça peut être
sur les démarches administratives mais
ça peut être aussi sur des questions
personnelles par rapport à leur charge
personnelle au dossier d'accessibilité
pour les locaux toute question relative
à leur installation
ces permanences et existe depuis 2012 en
ile de france dans les yvelines 67
médecins ont été reçus 45 sont installés
parmi eux huit exerce sur saint quentin
en yvelines dont trois généralistes la
qualité de vie un critère de choix pour
le lieu d'exercice des professionnels de
santé
nous avons la population médicale qui
s'est féminisée il faut donc
pour la femme médecin elle a besoin
d'avoir une crèche elle a besoin d'avoir
des écoles
elle a besoin si pour s'occuper de sa
vie familiale que tout ça soit à
disposition autour d'elle et autour de
son exercice
l'agencé régionale de santé vise aussi
des étudiants en médecine avec le
contrat d'engagement de service public
le financement des études en échange
d'un engagement d'installation dans une
zone sous denses il est habitants des
yvelines est désormais mof
jean-christophe jenson est l'un des cinq
lauréats du concours un des meilleurs
ouvriers de france dans la catégorie à
bâtir et des pâtisseries confiseries la
finale se déroulait fin octobre il nous
fait le plaisir d'être notre invité ce
soir bonsoir écrit jean-christophe gens
sont en soi alors vous êtes le chef
pâtissier de la maison lenôtre précisons
qu'à 51 ans vous étiez le doyen du
concours dans votre catégorie devenir
mof pour vous est-ce que c'était un rêve
un accomplissement
accomplissement non parce que j'espère
que ça va pas s'arrêter là un rêve oui
comme tout passionné je pense que c'est
sa récompense l'excellence dans plus de
200 métiers d'ailleurs pas que dans la
gastronomie
j'ai la chance de travailler dans ce
dans une maison qui est la maison
lenôtre qui a toujours poussé à
l'excellence véhicule toutes les valeurs
que ce titre porte haut et fort qu'ils
sont la tradition française autour de la
gastronomie en général et la chance que
cette maison a et transmet depuis
plus de 50 ans e
la totalité des métiers de la
gastronomie on le sait ce concours des
mof et un concours très difficile c'est
la deuxième fois que vous le présente y
est est-ce que c'était devenu une
obsession pour vous d'être mof une
obsession je sais pas si on peut dire
une obsession mais ténacité et moi ce
qui était d'abord très important c'était
de donner un exemple à mes enfants mes
propres enfants déjà parce que je leur
ai toujours dit depuis qu'ils sont nés
ne jamais abandonner donc j'ai été une
première fois l'échec était compliquée
et c'est un bel exemple de montrer que
c'est jamais perdu qu'il faut qu'il faut
s'acharner effectivement une part
d'autres sessions quels sont les
ingrédients du succès vous disiez le
travail l'expérience aussi au sein de la
maison lenôtre me si vous êtes passé
notamment par le traiteur raynier
marchetti
c'est cette expérience qui fait la
différence la passion aussi ses atouts
mois sans ma femme et mes enfants je
serai pas sur plateau aujourd'hui ça
commence par là c'est un soutien
familial
ensuite c'est
la passion c'est un entourage
professionnel et un soutien
professionnel puisque c'est un
un concours qui nécessite un budget oui
donc qu'est-ce qui a été soutenue en
très grande partie par la maison lenôtre
à qui je dois ça c'est l'ensemble des
collaborateurs de la maison qui vous met
un petit message tous les jours et des
fois vous avez des petits coups de
faiblesse et là vous avez le petit
message qui vous redonne un coup de pied
dans le derrière et qui dit vas-y tu as
pas leurs actes de lâches et peut-être
tous mongla qui compte sur toi quoi
c'est un vrai marathon c'est ce concours
c'est sur deux ans au total la finale se
déroule sur quatre jours
c'est ça 30 30 heures et demie de
concours un jour de préparation de
l'installation et après trois grosses
journées pour tous réalisés sur place
on réalise on arrivait du sucre en
morceaux et puis on fait des sucres des
pièces montées en sucre en chocolat de
sortir avec merveille à des merveilles
sucré alors voir le concours sur sur
deux ans est ce que c'est une période de
sa vie on est justement sa vie
personnelle de côté parce qu'on se dédit
complètement à ce concours comme
confirme je vous confirme il ya moi les
amis ça faisait
et quatre mois qui m'avait pas vu les
amis la famille ma femme la première
donc c'est pour ça que ce soutien il est
nécessaire parce que on y consacre tous
mes fans pour ma part bien sûr et je
pense que ça passe par là c'est vous
avez raconté hier quelqu'un qui était
intéressé ça va jusqu'à se dire quand on
se prépare le couteau il à cet endroit
là et à chaque fois que je vais faire le
concours que je vais fermer blanc ce que
les examens blancs il faudra toujours
qu'il soit cet endroit là parce que le
jour du concours je vais y aller le
chercher les yeux fermés je soirée où il
est et ça c'est des minutes des secondes
qu'on perd pas et passer à la chasse
c'est c'est vraiment la chasse aux temps
c'est la course autant avec la qualité
maximum et vitesse et précipitation ça
va pas ensemble
donc vous imaginez ce qu'on doit arriver
à faire quand vous parlez de l'épreuve
finale qui s'est déroulé sur plus de 30
heures le thème c'était hier aujourd'hui
et demain comment ça vous a inspiré ce
thème alors ça m'a inspiré
disons que je voulais d'abord faire
passer un message qui est très fort
aujourd'hui c'est
au delà de l'écologie manger sain
et c'est essayons de préserver le peu de
temps qu'on est sur terre de pas trop
laisser d'empreintes négative et il ya
une phrase que j'aime beaucoup qui dit
nous n'empruntons pas la terre à nos
parents non nous n'héritons pas de la
terre de nos parents nous l'empruntons à
nos enfants
donc ça veut tout dire ça veut dire que
il faut qu'on leur laisse quelque chose
de le plus sain possible et donc du coup
je me suis dit hier aujourd'hui demain
on utilise
le
l'énergie renouvelable hier on utilisait
des moulins à vent pour faire de la
farine
demain on utilisera de plus en plus des
éoliennes pour faire de l'électricité
donc j'ai fait un lien donc j'ai fait un
moulin en chocolat j'ai fait une
éolienne tout en soi et autour de ça
j'ai fait des produits pour être
cohérent et parce que je défends ça
qu'avec des produits de la région
donc j'ai des pommes de chez gaillard
qui est dans les yvelines qui fait des
pommes extraordinaire j'ai du miel
sauvage qui est de des yvelines du miel
d'été du miel de printemps dans
différentes recettes de la farine de la
beauce
donc j'ai essayé de de prendre les
produits les plus nobles possible et de
palais
et des formes et d'essayer de faire
quelque chose qu'il ait un qui respecte
tous ceux qui produisent et donc cinq
lauréats sur 15 dans cette catégorie
pâtisserie confiserie on arrive déjà à
la fin de cet entretien juste précisant
que vous avez dû prêter serment une fois
que vous avez été désigné mof l'une des
valeurs justement dans ce serment c'est
le partage transmettre pour vous c'est
important s'est senti un avenir aussi
dans ce métier c'est primordial c'est
quand on est parent on commence par ça
avec nos enfants c'est des signes
d'empreintes et ben moi je pense qu on
est on est sur terre pour ça pour
laisser une empreinte et donc on la
laisse avec les parents la laisse avec
les amis on la laisse au travail par la
transmission de ce que nos pères nous
ont appris et quand c'est une passion
c'est une joie de voir les autres qui
vous dépasse à un moment donné c'est ce
qui se passe c'est un jeune qui m'a
beaucoup aidé et que j'ai aidé que je
vais encore aider pour un autre concours
voilà bah il ya une on avait les larmes
aux yeux ensemble quoi oui on est prêtes
merci jean christophe gens sont d'accord
avec nous n'est au mof dans la catégorie
pâtisserie confiserie et précisons que
l'on pourra vous retrouvez à partir du
20 novembre à l'atelier éphémère à paris
vous animerez un pop-up entièrement
consacrée à l'art de la pâte et de la
pâtisserie merci d'avoir été avec noens
héros et des nouvelles de nos deux
yvelinois à présent engager dans la 11e
route du rhum la course transatlantique
en solitaire entre saint malo et la
guadeloupe
on commence par la mauvaise nouvelle
louis burton abandonne le skipper de
l'imoca bureau vallée a subi une grave
avarie c'était hier une poulie arracher
un trou de 30 cm dans le puits à tribord
est dérouté vers le port de roscoff
laurent boli temps a tout tenté mais les
réparations se sont avéré impossible lé
système électrique et hydraulique et en
a gravement endommagé
en revanche les nouvelles sont
meilleures pour éric bellion engagé sur
son bateau hors catégorie comme un seul
homme il était depuis hier stoppé dans
sa course à cause de vents violents mais
il a pu repartir éric bellion est
actuellement à 14e
tous les signaux sont au vert aussi du
côté des féminines de vélizy
villacoublay en nationale 3 c'est du
volley ball les yvelinois se sont
imposés 3 sets à 0 contre châteaudun ce
week-end et conserve donc la tête du
championnat
mickeal et demi d'euros sur des images
de patrick jacques de dixmude les
féminines de vélizy peuvent exulter les
sportifs viennent de remporter leur
cinquième victoire de la saison six
matches disputés leurs victimes du jour
châteaudun lévisienne s'impose dans leur
gymnase 3 sets à 0 le score 25 à 20 25
11 et 25 à 8
balade de santé non le premier sac
n'était pas la réalité sociale et
justement c'est en psycho logiquement se
mettre dedans et après par la suite
effectivement ça c'est rodez on a été
plus propre dans le fond que je cède
comme satisfait par rapport à la
causerie d'avant match
justement on a essayé d'appuyer sur le
fait de jouer ensemble se faire plaisir
et d'obtenir le jeu qu'on a par a tenus
sur les derniers matches dans la
régularité donc bonne réaction des
filles avec cette victoire les
bélizienne conserve la première place du
championnat de nationale 3 devant
argenteuil et le promu ne s'enflamme pas
donc l'installer c'est une année de
plaisir maintenant les filles commencent
à chercher justement à faire des
résultats
mais les objectifs du club
ces deux matches 7 se maintenir moi
c'est d'essayer de faire le tableau et
puis ça va et puis ici sont gourmandes
donc on va voir ça pour continuer à
rêver d'une montée en nationale 2 vélizy
devra s'imposer le 17 novembre prochain
face à son dauphin au classement
argenteuil
une victoire et les yvelinoises pourrait
déjà une sérieuse option sur la première
place avec moi sur ce plateau mélanie
poquet bonsoir ça cette semaine a lancé
les commémorations de la première guerre
mondiale 11 novembre de nombreuses
communes célébreront les 100 ans de la
fin du conflit mondial à 14,18 une
période de l'histoire qui inspire aussi
les artistes mélanie votre coup de coeur
de la semaine est un ouvrage pour
enfants la guerre en mille morceaux
raconte l'histoire du soldat macha un
jeune homme envoyé au front dès la
mobilisation en août 14
ce soldat machin de son nom civil
maturana pas existé alain serres son
créateur a choisi d'en faire un anonyme
un soldat parmi les 73 millions
mobilisés durant le conflit
le soldat machin c'est un soldat moyens
qui ressemble à tous les autres
à l'époque la faute de la france rurale
il est bien sûr issu d'un petit village
et comme le raconte la légende le cliché
je dirais bien il était en plein champ
en train de travailler quand le tocsin a
sonné je suis donc son combat au
quotidien
oui avec subtilité alain serres ne cacha
rien pourtant de l'auteur de l'horreur
du conflit les tranchées le froid
intense de l'hiver la chaleur de l'été
les gaz la peur les assauts alors l'idée
à grégory n'est bien sûr pas d'effrayer
mais de faire comprendre l'intensité du
conflit
ce qu'ont vécu nos ancêtres alain serres
a travaillé avec zaho the usa eu voilà
je le prononce bien pour les
illustrations et plusieurs planches sont
accompagnées de photographies sur ces
photographies des objets d'époque une
cinquantaine alors tous ont été
rassemblées par l'auteur lui même
alain serres au fil des années on y
trouve un clairon des figurants plomb
une lanterne et à l'image un stylo créé
par un poilus dans les tranchées à
l'aide de deux doubles collées entre
elles j'ai exclu tous les objets qui
étaient strictement mai
deere c'est pas du tout le sens de ma
petite collection
je voulais qu'il y ait du sens de la vie
on peut les ombres humaine derrière
derrière chacun de ces objets voilà un
autre moyen d'apprendre sur le conflit
si les deux soldats de l'époque ont tous
disparu leurs objets témoignent du
quotidien l'histoire de mathurin est à
lire dans la guerre en mille morceaux
publié aux éditions rue du monde
merci mélanie on vous retrouve juste
après ce journal pour un magazine 7,8
culture entièrement consacrée au
souvenir de la guerre de 14 18
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]